insanity. It's FOX across
America with Jimmy failla.
>> But there was Joe.
>> Say in the bill they passed
would help me you.
Inflation
is soaring and my same gone.
>> Joe can dream he's talking
to.
I mean he's insane.
Sunny days in the basement when
no friends.
The scene hundreds crime.
But the press all over them.
And the shaking hands with
>> James Taylor's back on the
White House lawn they must be
pass another counterproductive
inflation bill joining us now
on the show someone knows an
awful lot about that you talk
about an embarrassment of radio
rich is okay. This is just our
Booker showing off nobody even
believe me this morning when I
said it was going to happen.
Stuart Varney is in studio can
you confirm of flattery is the
mother's milk of radio
and television.
>> Yeah he he is here at his
own free People were asked if
this was a hostage situation
you can blink twice to confirm
your okay I am perfectly OK.
>> I am ready willing and able
to talk to you this is a big
deal. This is a big deal I want
to start with your series and
I'm gonna get into some
grown-up conversations but
American built is hosted by
Stuart Varney.
>> It's Monday nights at
09:00PM on FB on FOX business.
I find American bill to be so
perfectly timed to this moment,
why because it's a celebration
of American exceptionalism at a
time we don't have a lot of
that in our politics.
Well it's a celebration of what
you can do that's what America
did do given the right amount
of coverage dynamism and drive
I I suspect that when no longer
that with become the no can do
guys as opposed to the can do
goes it's we're to let me say
that Stuart Varney is that
crazy someone who's cuff you
know covered politics barack
obama once won the presidency
on a message of yes we can
exactly which in this day and
age they be like check your
privilege, half white guy.
What do you mean, yes we can
easy for you to set you can't
do anything in America without
a lawsuit for every
single thing that ever happens
at any time about the hold
everything up yeah you can't do
things today you can't build
things can you I mean in all
seriousness you.
>> You can't just get on with
it and do it.
They think about this like
something something like
building a
wall politically OK in theory,
a wall would be you know it
today job but then you get
lawsuits and zoning and you
know environmental protections
and everything Embassy in
between.
>> The point is now you've got
no wall.
Trump managed to build it was
300 miles of wall. Yeah despite
intense opposition despite a
lawsuit solar as it. He is
a guy who could do things but
America he's a can do
guy Biden is the exact opposite
when you think about it what
the can this guy actually do
how well listen.
>> He can shake hands with
invisible people. I've never
seen you do of army has seen a
lot of impressive things and
watching the like that Barneys
a talented Kavanaugh 5 years
younger than the press I got a
way to go before. I like that.
>> Well listen everybody always
says he's Jimmy Carter but to
his credit. It took Jimmy
Carter for years to do it Biden
didn't one and a half
absolutely it is kind of an
accomplishment that we're in
the position. We're in is it
not we should have seen it
coming, you know what I mean
you really should have seen
this coming Biden's job was to
be Trump. Once you've beaten
Trump, okay, we don't know, but
I guess it and then he goes
into a series of gaffes and
yeses up all the time.
This is not a president you can
have a great deal of confidence
in that you gotta say long live
Joe Biden because behind in
is kamala
Harris haha it really is best
move ever when you think about
it you know stayed alive,
What a fire wall he's got
their. Stuart Varney is in
studio American built He hosted
himself as on FBN Mondays at 9
o'clock.
>> Really quickly things that
jumped out at me on the episode
less Las Vegas, I'm heading to
Las Vegas next week to do
stand-up at the red rock
resort. It is sold out you
can't get tickets but Stuart
Varney can still get in but the
point they rebuild After I
guess you know the premise
being that the Mafia was kind
of thrown out the billion airs
came in the corporation's came
in how did they do that I mean
it's fascinating to me Wall
Street came in with the money
that was and showed that you
could make a profit
and a gambling den like Las
Vegas when I when I think of
Vegas I was thinking my
goodness me what would Vegas
look like it was a government
project had it not being
private enterprise building
this brilliant miraculous place
in the middle of the desert
what would the government have
done with it it would look
blood he awful what it's all
about and that's the that's the
message here.
You can do stuff with private
enterprise and it was just get
out the way thank you I will
quote. Ronald Reagan.
You know government is not the
solution to our problem
government is the problem, but
it's true
and is that not the point of a
lot of the series is that we
were a lot more efficient with
less government 3 '04 '05
we could that we should bear in
mind. Hi,
I'm from the government I only
want to help Yahoo is that it
was appalling attempted
American accent like the lights
still at a party know, I've
convinced everyone that you're
faking it you grew up in New
Jersey in fact I know as the
stock had the stock with Mike
I'm not buying the whole Varney
thing I know it
I've seen him at the Molly
pitcher stop get the coffee
to get a call of the take this,
but it's good the way you do it
it's like a ventriloquist act
and what you get your energy
graduate half my age we speak a
lot of energy for a guy you
know, I'm like Stuart Varney, a
like a dog with a job and I'll
explain.
>> You know you go to the
airport and you see that
bomb-sniffing dog with a
drug-sniffing dog sniffing
everybody's luggage and his
tales always wagon because he
can't believe they're counting
on a white Labrador to save the
plane.
>> I am the media equivalent of
a white Labrador my tail was
wagging his I can't believe
they're counting on me to sniff
the bags and save the plane.
So I'm always here what does
that make me I hopefully a guy
who's not about to throw a
tennis ball because I'll chase
it away and then we'll have no
fast enough in the bags that's
all for the laugh and but we
have Stuart Varney in the House
did you cover on your show the
fact that Nancy Pelosi is
trying to get people to dismiss
inflation because it's a global
issue, but as that might be the
worst consolation to the person
affected by ever heard what
Nancy Pelosi had to say today
was pure desperation.
>> I mean she knows that the
big issue in this election.
A few days away is inflation.
She can't accept that she can
to she's got to get around that
somehow or other so she simply
we've got to change the subject
you really can't change the
subject at this late date,
especially because inflation is
to some degree to a large
degree your fault. You are the
people who ended energy
independence. You all the
people that just 10% of the
economy in cash into the
economy. He spent trillions and
here we are with inflation.
You cannot go to the country
and say it's not my fault,
it up you can't do It's such
bad messaging because you know
if America supposed to be the
shining city on a hill.
It seems so weird that they're
closing argument is we should
see the other
what do people we live Hunter
city the message is always.
>> You know it's not good no
not that I got that wrong.
The message from the Democrats
is deliberately
all the fuss Kaisha that said a
stupid Longwood but it is it's
deliberately let's not talk
about the border.
Let's not talk about to
inflation, let's not talk about
the economy because we're not
doing very well that when was
the last time
you ever had in a conversation
I don't know if social circle
as well as the last center
set January the 6th really fast
gotten to me, I'm telling you
I'm gonna vote on that.
>> Have you ever heard I
haven't made them in the wrong
social circles I Stewart
parties in studio telling it
like it is
you are a big Jillian percent
right is that nobody cares you
know what's funny to their
credit, I'll give him credit
for this.
>> The Washington Post
acknowledged that last week
they said Democrats have failed
to make this a referendum on
January 6th really failed.
It's because their policies
have taken us to a place where
we can't afford superficial
fights meaning I was a luxury
under Trump we could pretend
for 3 years the Trump was a
Russian asset, nothing else to
do. OK now we've got real
problems, you know we don't
have the luxury
of going back to Joseph most
people now Stuart when you
bring up January 6 the most
shocking thing that happened
that day was the price of gas
the price of eggs in the price
of Brent, yeah.
I don't mean to
digress people had been a view
of the code of the
rotisserie chicken index Before
the pandemic every single
supermarket in America had
those rich history, chicken
things are all a lie and use it
was 5.99 a chicken fast forward
to today and he's a 99 on
9.99.
I was in a fancy supermarket in
New York City over
the weekend sit a runner I the
cascade of the next pensive
stuff that they're rotisserie
chicken was $15 stop by to snow
stopping it. That was the stand
a chicken
look at that that's what
inflation that's inflation
that's real that everybody sees
that kind of stuff is crazy
like I'm turning tricks behind
the gas station to pay for a
gallon 87 octane. Time
was I'd only been doing that
for the love of the game that
act of doing it for the gas and
no one left.
But I will tell you this look
is somebody who you know I
spent a lot of time driving a
taxi in New York City.
In my garage and this is no
exaggeration I said this on the
5 on Friday. I was so in the
minority ethnically in my
garage with all of these
wonderful men from every
country on Earth some from
other planets as well I'm not
gonna lie. There was some there
are some time travelers in that
garage, okay, but none of
them and I mean this they'd
always referred to me as the
white guy that was a running
joke low like it was the white
guy say it was literally on
like but I've really got to
know a very you know a heavily
divers crab
none of them care about
anything the Democrats are
pushing whether we're talking
about climate change if you
live in the inner city and like
you said your rotisserie
chicken has tripled in price.
The last thing you care about
what the weather is going to do
10 years from now right that is
such a luxury I mean I don't
use the term white privilege
but I consider white privilege,
but it's only white coastal
elites that care about climate
change he elites of grab
control of our political
institutions and Ben them in a
fall left Conaway yeah and then
they walk away from the
problems that they have created
is it so certainly it's of
California and the Northeastern
United States.
Make me throw up I don't need
to get to haha they've
recruited they've created a
country which ikebana recognize
from the one that I came to
nearly 50 years ago.
That's what's so crazy to me is
everybody shares that sentiment
even if they've migrated
recently like when you see how
they're hemorrhaging Latino
support. One of the reasons
support is it starting to
resemble the country they fled,
Elaine, the crazy and I they
don't get that, but it's so
hard to sell oppression to
people who are actually
oppressed. You know they sell
well in this country because we
have no perspective the can
admit it. Yeah that can't be
honest and that just can't they
have no answer so the walk
away.
No answer walk away. That's
just not good enough now we got
to change course if he could
have
some honesty. So I'm not in the
game. Imagine that no one with
you and let you know what else
they need they're going to need
something to watch on election
night because the Democrats are
not going want to watch these
returns. So allow me to every
election night in 2016 oh do I
all the and I am so excited to
get called a white-supremacist
by joy Reid on election day
last year my over under for
white supremacy is 8 '05 on
election night they'll be
showing capital footage January
6 foot by 8.30 it's going to be
a bad one.
>> But you know what they
deserve and it's a byproduct of
their own making is it not it
is 100% a byproduct of their
own making and I think there's
going to be a red wave I pray I
hope there's a red wave that's
going to happen. Stuart Varney
was in our studio we will
always have this this is a big
Really quick before you go
American bill Monday night 9
o'clock you can watch it
tonight on FB N
not only hear about Vegas.
The Verrazano bridge even the
Houston Astrodome. Which is
fascinating because the Astro's
just beat our New York Yankees,
true and that happens what are
you going to do
I didn't I didn't bet that one
so you'll be happy to know I
don't need to crash in your
office again disaster don't was
something that I heard about
when it was built living in
England in the 1960's.
Back then in a 5060 years ago
we were so impressed look at
these Americans did but
goodness me an AK
condition has Now we don't
think quite the same way about
what America can do now we
don't but that's why I think
the show is so good if you
watch the show. It's like a
half times speech of America
was a ball team a football team
because we're not playing
championship ball right now.
But we got a good half times
speech this show really makes
you believe in what makes
America what it is it does
nothing going on in Washington
doesn't go that's what we're
trying to pull Washington
within to Washington is selling
this car out for parts right
now OK. Stuart Varney is got
this car on the lot the engines
run in the talk it's look good
I'm telling you I'm a believer
again and I